♪ ♪ ♪
- On dit : "Bonjour, journaliste
pour La Pige", puis ça dit
quelque chose à tout le monde.
- On est la plus grande
salle de rédaction, en fait,
au Saguenay-Lac-Saint-Jean.
- Bienvenue au journal La Pige,
la publication des étudiants
en journalisme du Cégep de
Jonquière. Plus d'une trentaine
de finissants se relaient
à chaque année pour produire
un bimensuel imprimé
et un quotidien numérique.
Ce programme a 50 ans.
10 000 jeunes y ont suivi
une formation depuis
sa création. Le poids de
la tradition semble donner
des ailes à ces journalistes
en herbe, encore aujourd'hui.
SAMUEL DUCHAÎNE, étudiant, Art,
Techno. médias, Cégep Jonquière
- Un militaire va décider de
sacrifier sa vie, il le voit
comme un devoir, bien nous
aussi, on voit un peu ça comme
un devoir. C'est notre rôle
à jouer dans la société.
- Les étudiants du coin
pouvaient imaginer encore
récemment se trouver un travail
d'été et, peut-être un jour,
un travail à temps plein
au Quotidien de Saguenay,
un des plus vieux journaux
au Québec, créé il y a 135 ans.
Ce n'est plus vraiment
le cas aujourd'hui.
Comment vous avez réagi?
- Ça a été un choc.
- Je suis plus inquiète de
mon avenir de journaliste.
- La nouvelle est tombée
à la mi-août. Le groupe
Capitales Médias, propriétaire
du Quotidien de Saguenay et de
cinq autres journaux quotidiens
régionaux a demandé
la protection des tribunaux
contre ses créanciers.
Les plus anciens journalistes
risquent de perdre le tiers
de leur fonds de retraite.
NORMAND BOIVIN, chef
des nouvelles, Le Quotidien
- C'est ça qu'il y a de plus
tannant aussi parce que...
quand même, quand ça fait
37 ans que t'es dans
une entreprise puis que t'avais
une certaine confiance envers
les propriétaires, puis que
tu te fais jouer des tours,
c'est pas plaisant.
- L'absence ou la disparition
d'un quotidien au Saguenay-Lac-
Saint-Jean, ça va être une perte
énorme. Il va y avoir un silence
qui va s'installer.
- Malgré la réduction
de ses effectifs de près
de la moitié depuis cinq ans,
le journal du Saguenay joue
encore un rôle central dans
la vie sociale, culturelle
et sportive de la région.
DENIS BOUCHARD, directeur
général, Le Quotidien
- Dans les conseils municipaux
importants, comme Alma par
exemple, qui est la deuxième
plus grande ville, on est seuls.
Des conseils d'administration
des commissions scolaires,
on est seuls. Le CIUSS...
Pourtant, c'est très important,
des budgets, pas loin de 800
millions de budget, puis il y a
des décisions qui se prennent
sur des coupures, des transferts
de service, et si on n'est pas
témoins de ça, on risque d'en
subir les conséquences.
Je pense que le rôle social
est indéniable.
LILIA GAULIN, étudiante, Art,
Techno. médias, Cégep Jonquière
- Pour moi, c'est impensable
de voir les médias de Capitales
Médias s'éteindre parce qu'on
doit avoir une information
régionale de qualité.
- Les finissants de l'école de
journalisme de Jonquière sont
conscients des transformations
profondes que subit le monde
de l'information. Mais
leur enthousiasme est intact.
PIERRICK PICHET, étudiant, Art,
Techno. médias, Cégep Jonquière
- Lorsque que quelque chose
survient, bien en cinq secondes,
ça se retrouve sur le web, puis
en une journée, ça se retrouve
dans le papier. Donc c'est
certain que, à mon sens à moi,
le numérique offre plus
d'avantages, puis c'était
quelque chose auquel on
s'attendait depuis longtemps.
Je pense que les médias papiers
sont en déclin depuis
des lustres, puis c'est
une certaine fatalité.
- Le syndicat des journalistes
espère contrer cette fatalité.
Il travaille d'arrache-pied à
mettre sur pied une coopérative
issue du milieu qui pourrait
se porter acquéreur en tout
ou en partie du journal.
LOUIS TREMBLAY, président,
Syndicat des comm. du Quotidien
- Tout le monde sait que,
dans l'industrie, il y a
des grands journaux qui risquent
de tomber à brève échéance,
donc c'est peut-être
une occasion qu'on a de mettre
en place un modèle d'affaires
différent.
- Des engagements de plusieurs
centaines de milliers de dollars
ont été reçus. Mais cela reste
insuffisant pour l'instant.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les apprentis journalistes
voient la situation actuelle
comme un défi, qu'ils s'engagent
à relever, malgré la très grande
fragilité des médias
d'information.
- C'est à nous, justement,
d'aller plus loin que ce qui se
fait actuellement, de vérifier
les faits et de s'assurer que
l'information qu'on donne, elle est bonne et pertinente.